Salut, aujourd’hui j'entame mon 3ème mois de MentalVlog
Oui j'entame ce soir parce qu'en fait on est mardi soir alors que c'est la vidéo du mercredi
Petit retour, quand même, sur ces 2 mois écoulés
j'entame le 3ème mois, donc ça veut dire que je commence à prendre conscience de l'ampleur, un peu du délire
parce que vraiment il arrive des trucs cool grâce au MentalVlog
Je vous rencontre souvent, durant les spectacles, aux hallucinations collectives ou sur mon spectacle en tournée
D'ailleurs, ce samedi là, le samedi 5 je serai à la Valette du Var dans le Sud
Si vous êtes dans le coin venait au spectacle on fera une vidéo après
Ça ça sera cool, ça sera la vidéo du lundi du coup, celle que je mettrai lundi
et puis sinon c'est quand même un petit peu tendu
en fait, d’être en flux tendu justement
parce que je fais toujours les vidéos en temps réel parce que j'en ai pas d'avance
ce qui veut dire qu'il faut toujours que je pense à la vidéo du lendemain
Et ce week end
Petite surprise
je suis tombé malade,  j'ai été malade samedi et dimanche, j'espère que ça c'est pas trop vu dans les vidéos
mais j'étais vraiment... samedi, dimanche, lundi. Ça m'a mis un coup en fait
et encore j'étais encore en capacité de pouvoir produire des vidéos
mais je me suis dit comment ça va se passer le jour, où vraiment, je ne pourrais pas bouger
Je vais pas essayer de mentaliser les microbes en me filmant depuis mon lit. C'est pas possible ça.
Alors je crois que je vais tourner d'avance, quand j'aurai le temps parce que ça fait un truc en plus à faire
On ne s'en sortira jamais
Je vais faire une série de 4 ou 5 vidéos sur 'Comment résoudre un Rubik's Cube très facilement pour toute sa vie'.
Tu vois les méthodes de résolutions de Rubik's Cube.
Et le jour, où je serais très malade, parce que ça peut arriver en fait.
J'y ai pas pensé mais ça peut arriver
et bien j'aurai juste à les mettre en ligne, à faire l'habillage et les mettre en ligne et...
ce sera une manière de ne pas arrêter le MentalVlog
Tout en pouvant prendre, 4-5 jours de repos si besoin et j'espère ne pas en avoir besoin en fait
J'espère ne pas être malade dans ma vie, d'une manière générale.
Sinon on est à plus de 1600 abonnés, on doit être à 1625 je crois 1630 au moment où je vous parle
C'est... Baaaa. C'est comme ça
Si vous êtes pas abonnés, abonnez vous.
En cliquant sur le petit logo qui il y a dans le coin. Vous pouvez vous abonner avec ça
A 2500 abonnés, qui est mon : DEFI 2500
on en profitera pour organiser un apéro en live en fait
Un apéro virtuel bien sûr puisque chacun sera chez soi avec des soft.
L'abus d'alcool est dangereux pour la santé
Et on pourra se parler, discuter, durant quelques heures, se faire des trucs de mentalismes directement en direct comme ça
Voilà pour ce petit point récap'
Mais aujourd'hui je vous donne donc une astuce parce que c'est le mercredi, c'est le jour des astuces. Et je vous donne l'astuce du Post it
Plusieurs fois dans les commentaires vous m'avez demandé si j'avais des astuces pour gagner au jeu du Post it
Bien sûr que j'ai des astuces pour ça
Alors voici mes 4 astuces pour gagner plus facilement au jeu du Post it
Pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas le jeu du Post it se joue à plusieurs
chaque personne va recevoir un Post it sur son front
sur lequel il y aura marqué un nom que tout le monde connait. Ça peut être quelqu'un de très connu, de célèbre
comme ça peux être... quelqu'un de sa famille, comme ça peut être quelqu'un de virtuel
comme Dieu par exemple
Ça peut être Homer Simpson, voilà
peu importe
Donc chaque personne a un nom comme ça de coller sur son front et doit retrouver qui il est
Qui écrit le nom sur le Post it? et bien un autre joueur le fait secrètement
donc il y a une phase préparatoire à ce jeu
et c'est là qu'intervient la 1ère astuce.
La 1ère astuce, c'est au lieu de vous creusez la tête, pour savoir qui vous allez écrire sur le Post it pour mettre à votre voisin, en fait, à un autre joueur
Faite semblant d'écrire ou de réfléchir
mais identifier celui qui va écrire pour vous
Je ne vous dit pas de regarder ce qu'il va écrire, ça non surtout pas
Je vous dis de bien regarder qui est cette personne en fait
Essayer d'analyser, essayer de vous mettre à sa place en fait
C'est forcément quelqu'un que vous connaissez puisque vous jouez avec
donc vous connaissez ces codes, vous connaissez ces réactions et vous allez voir comment elle va réagir, en fait
Est ce qu'elle a une idée tout de suite, est ce qu'elle va réfléchir un petit peu
Est ce que c'est plutôt quelqu'un de timide, quelqu'un de plutôt fantasque
Est ce que cette personne là, regarde  les Post it des autres avant d'écrire le sien.
Dans ce cas là, je vous donne un indice, il y a de forte chance, qu'elle s'inspire de ce que les autres ont écrit
Tout simplement parce qu'on agit avec des connexions mentales.
Une idée en envoie une autre comme pour les brainstorming
et bien là pour ça c'est pareil, on se nourrit, en fait, de l'environnement
Regardez, un petit peu, ce qu'il y a dans la pièce
donc regardez cette personne, regardez ce qu'elle regarde, ce qu'elle fait et comment elle pourrait réfléchir
car ça c'est déjà un bon indice
La 2ème astuce consiste à déterminer, à l'avance, qu'elle est la personne la plus expressive
Dans les convives
Puisque quand vous allez poser votre question. Par exemple, votre question va être "Suis je un homme?"
Les gens doivent dire oui ou non, puisque dans ce jeu on ne peut répondre que par oui ou par non
Ça on y reviendra
Vous devez déterminer la personne la plus expressive,
parce que cette personne là, très expressive,  vont vous donner des réponses avant de formuler et moi voici ma règle
Tant que la personne n'a pas verbalisé le Oui ou le Non, je peux changer de question ^^
Faut pas jouer avec moi en fait
C'est pas une arnaque c'est tout à fait légale, la règle dit:
On doit poser une question et les personnes doivent  répondre par oui ou par non
tant que la personne n'a pas répondu verbalement
On peut changer de question
on est pas obligé, obligé
Regardez la personne qui répond avec son visage
soit avec un mouvement de tête,
soit avec un sourire, soit avec un *expression du visage*
pour le non
qui est la plus expressive et sur qui vous allez pouvoir lire les réponses avant de verbaliser
qui permet quand vous avez la réponse en non verbal, de dire "Non, non, non, non, non"
je change de question c'est pas ça.
Petite astuce, petite arnaque quoi
La 3ème astuce consiste à... avoir une vérité
En fait, c'est vraiment des astuces embrouilles hein.
Je suis en train de m'en rendre compte
La 4ème sera plus légale
La 3ème astuce, ça consiste à reformuler avec une vérité, c'est à dire
Avant de jouer,
vous faites un petit récap'
mais c'est une... c'est pas vraiment une question.
Un exemple concret, si au tour d'avant j'ai demandé si j'étais célèbre
et que les gens ont dit oui
Maintenant je vais vouloir savoir si je suis célèbre que en France ou si je suis célèbre dans le monde entier
Mais ça c'est une autre question
Du coup, je vais reformuler une vérité
Le fait que je suis célèbre
avec une question indirecte
Le fait d'inclure le monde entier
et donc là il faut jouer un peu la comédie,
Il y a pas de secret
Sortez les oscars, Di caprio est parmi nous
"Pfff ok, donc là ça commence à être un peu compliqué... donc... je pars du dernier point je suis célèbre dans le monde entier
euh... et donc si je suis célèbre dans le monde entier c'est... parce que je suis"
Encore une fois, vous allez remarquer sur le visage de votre cible, de l'astuce n°2, si c'est bon ou pas
Et quand bien même, bien souvent il y a bonheur, il y a toujours quelqu'un pour dire
"Ah non non on a pas dit ça"
Dans certaines soirée on m'a jeté des objets à force de se rendre compte de... ce que je faisais
donc faites le à vos risques et périls
La 4ème astuce ce sont les 10 questions que j'ai référencées
pour fabriquer mon entonnoir, parce qu'en réalité ce jeu c'est un
Il y a tout le champs des possibles qui pouvait être au départ,
Vous pouvez être vous même
On a pu écrire votre propre prénom
en disant : "oulala ça va être difficile"
Et c'est un des plus facile à trouver
comme vous pouvez être quelqu'un de très connu ou quelqu'un de fictif, comme je vous ai dis
ou encore même le chien du voisin
Vous pouvez être n'importe qui
comme point commun, vous avez le fait que toutes les personnes qui jouent au jeu avec vous
connaissent la personne que vous êtes sur le Post it
Une fois qu'on a joué un petit peu au Qui est ce géant dans notre esprit parmi toutes les possibilités
Ça nous permet d'avoir un vrai rail de pensée
et de trier et d'aboutir assez facilement à la réponse
Je vous donne mes 10 questions principales qui me permettent, moi, de trouver très très vite
La 1ère question que je pose c'est: est ce que je suis réel ou fictif?
et à ça j'exige de la part des autres joueurs une réponse précise.
par exemple, David Duchovny est réel mais Fox Mulder est fictif
Ma 2ème questions c'est: Est ce que je suis connu ou anonyme?
Est ce que je suis un homme ou une femme?
Ensuite je m'attache à trouver le secteur, en fait, où évolue cette personne.
Donc si c'est quelqu'un de connu, je vais chercher dans le politique, dans le sportive, dans l'artistique, dans le religieux.
Si c'est quelqu’un de pas connu je vais chercher à savoir si c'est le cercle amical, familial, professionnel
une fois que j'ai ça, je m'attache encore à autre chose c'est à savoir si la personne est vivante ou morte?
Et bé oui
Ça aussi ça donne une piste
Après je pose une question qui surprend, en général, mais faite le c'est assez intéressant pour votre recherche
Je demande si mon personnage est composé d'un nom ou d'un prénom ou juste d'un seul nom
Au moment, où vous aurez vraiment votre rail, ça vous aidera beaucoup à faire vos choix pour composer vos réponses
Ensuite je demande si cette personne me connait et peut prononcer mon prénom
Petite arnaque
Il y a encore 2 questions dans une
Cette question là évidemment je la pose selon toutes les réponses que j'ai eu avant
Ensuite, je commence à gratter pour essayer de trouver le sous univers du 1er cercle
Si par exemple, le 1er cercle c'était... quelqu'un qui fait parti du cinéma
Je vais chercher si c'est plus des comédies, des westerns, des films d'action, des films d'horreur
Si c'est quelqu'un qui vient du milieu de la musique, je vais chercher si c'est de la pop, du rock, du rap
etc... etc...
Je vais chercher un peu le sous univers
Ensuite je cherche le pays, uniquement à ce moment là. Je cherche le pays...
Je cherche le pays si ça a pas été clairement défini, en tout cas d'ici là. Donc je cherche le pays
D'où la personne vient.
Et si je suis bloqué, si je suis figé ou si j'ai un petit peu de temps devant moi d'après moi par rapport aux autres joueurs
Je vais essayer de trouver le nombre de syllabes
qu'il y a dans le nom
Surtout si ce qu'il y a écrit sur mon Post it est composé d'un seul mot
dans ce cas là le nombre de syllabes va vraiment m'aider après par rapport à toutes les idées qui vont me venir
Voilà vous avez toutes mes astuces, en tout cas celles qui sont reproduisibles
pour gagner plus facilement au jeu du Post it. Amusez vous
Mettez moi dans les commentaires ce qu'on vous a mis de pire en fait comme nom quand vous avez joué à ce jeu là
Ça ça m'intéresse et puis ça donnera des idées à tout le monde pour essayer de piéger les autres joueurs lors d'une partie.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo. Si elle vous a plu, pensez à la partager
Abonnez vous à la chaîne, je vous les dis c'est important
Rendez vous samedi à la Valette du Var pour ce qui habitent près de Toulon.
Pour ceux, qui se pose la question de pourquoi j'ai fait la vidéo en avance c'est parce que demain j'ai rendez vous au YouTube Space pour la 1ère fois et j'ai hâte d'y aller.
Je vais vous faire une petite vidéo là bas
Et d'ici là, rendez vous demain, à 17h, pour le prochain MentalVlog
Ciao!